- Last time I was here,
Kelly also wasn't here.
(audience laughs)
That's weird, right?
It's weird.
No one's ever seen me and Kelly
Clarkson in the same room.
(audience laughs)
Maybe I'm her Clarkson Kent.
I'm starting to think
it was something I did.
Could she still be mad that
I voted for Justin Guarini?
(audience boos)
I regret the decision.
Every day, and especially today.
Last time I was here,
my friend Simu Liu was the guest host.
(audience cheers)
And we played a game
where I was lucky enough
to drink hot dog water.
Let's see that.
- [God] Come on, Kumail.
- [Kumail] I can do this all day.
(drum roll)
- [God] And this is hot dog water.
- Yeah.
(drum roll)
- [God] That's it. Mmmm.
- [Simu] Boba, boba, boba's right there.
- [God] What a lovely bouquet.
Hot dog water. Mmm.
Where's your superpowers now, huh?
- I give up.
- Fair enough.
- That is not a lie.
That is hot dog water.
- [God] That is hot dog water.
(audience cheers)
- I don't know why I keep coming back.
They also made me drink a cup of wasabi
as well as a shot of ranch dressing.
Both things I genuinely actually despise.
Horrible. My stomach
still has not recovered.
Aw, thank you.
That's so kind of you.
Thank you, Justin.
My God, this is great.
(audience cheers)
Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- Wait, is that what
happens when you're a host?
You get to drink whatever you ask for.
Okay, can I have a pineapple
smoothie right now?
Oh wow.
Look at that.
There's no whipped cream.
Hmm. Oh yeah.
(audience cheers)
Thank you.
- [Justin] You're very welcome.
- Thank you so much.
Wow. Pepto and pineapple
don't go well together.
Don't ever do that.
Other than that, I am happy to
be covering for Kelly today.
She was, you know, I've
never hosted a show before.
This is my first time hosting any show.
I've never hosted a show.
(audience cheers)
So she was kind enough
to leave me a note with some hosting tips,
specially for me.
So here we go.
This is a note from Kelly.
Hi Kumail.
Thank you for taking such
good care of my show.
Aww. Don't get ahead of
yourself Kelly, I just started.
Things could go south.
I truly appreciate you guest hosting
and making Marvel movies.
Oh, that's kind.
Here are a few tips
while you're at the show
that may help you.
Tip number one, compliment Ruben's suit.
He warms up the audience
(audience cheers)
and will get them extra warm
if you tell him he looks nice.
Man, you look really nice.
- Give it up for me man, come on. Yeah!
- That's very sharp.
That is very sharp.
Well done.
Tip number two, the band will play a sting
whenever you say,
"Welcome to Chippendales takeover."
(sting plays)
Yeah, thank you.
I should take you guys around.
That's an awesome thing to
just have happen in my life.
If you scream,
"I'm wearing lace underwear",
something awesome happens.
I'm wearing lace underwear!
(audience laughs)
Just kidding about that last one.
Thanks a lot, Kelly.
(audience cheers)
Thank you.
Have fun.
Another reason I'm
really excited to be here
is that we have many people
from the cast of my series
on the show today.
(audience cheers)
The show is called
"Welcome to Chippendales",
and you can see it now on Hulu.
That's right.
This is a "Welcome to
Chippendales" takeover.
(sting plays)
Thank you.
In this series, I play Steve Banerjee
the Indian immigrant who
created Chippendales.
People don't know this,
the story actually gets really dark
which is not what you'd expect.
There's double crossing, murder, drugs,
everything that's kind
of the exact opposite
of what you think when
you think of Chippendales.
Although there are plenty
of nearly naked men dancing,
so that's a plus.
Speaking of which, we have some
dancers here with us today.
(audience cheers)
What's up fellas?
How's it going?
Do us proud in the
Blake's Box Seats today.
I know Blake Shelton would be
proud to have you up there.
Thank you for being there.
So, are you guys okay like
showing us the moves right now?
Yeah? Jason, can we play some music?
(upbeat music)
Yeah! Yeah!
(audience cheers)
I'm actually not a good dancer.
My wife Emily will back me up on that.
She's not here today,
but you know, I'm not good at dancing.
I'd love to go dancing with her
but these video games won't
play themselves, you know?